I have to start with I'm very this is
completely off tangent I just have to
start and it's a question to you what is
it like for you rolling into a bar now
do you find people like getting very mad
at you for no reason or are pie polite
question I mean because it you played
you know the popularity of that show I'm
sure has made it very difficult in real
life I don't know I think people sort of
really enjoy hating him so I don't get
people angry with me or anything
people also definitely bow to you in
public at the bar people get used people
see people dance wedge their last yeah
yeah it's kind of wish I'll have a beer
whilst someone is over here like yeah
yes jumping into why I get to talk to
you guys today first of all
congratulations jeff has been trying to
make this movie since 2013 what what was
it like with him on set because was he
like a kid in a candy store
he's been trying so hard to make this
movie I remember thinking Jeff Tremaine
jackass this is gonna like motley crue
that this is gonna be the most insane
wild set ever in and pranks everywhere
but he was so focused because he's been
trying to get him made for us for so
long and he really cares about this
genre of music and this this ear in time
and he grew up now it's his time and he
loved it so he was so focused but also
he was having the best time ever he had
here like 80s rock blasting the whole
time I mean he also pulled pranks every
day and gave our DP of birthday there
was a it was our director of
photography's birthday that's amazing
for all three of you this is a unique
situation where the people you are
portraying is what really happened
they're all still alive they can all
talk about what really happened it makes
it for a very unique preparation process
because everything's available to you so
talk a little bit about what some of the
first things you did to get ready to
play these roles I think what it was the
guitar getting the guitar right for me I
already played but it's a very different
style and I think for me it was the
physical
t of Mik - you know he describes his the
ankylosing spondylitis very well in the
book so it was kind of trying to play
that they're not overdoing it in it and
it just being a parody of it because
it's obviously you know it's very
difficult but yeah that was kind of why
I did got you guys and and he's you're
made you a mate so tommylee already and
yeah so I'd go just plot the script on
his desk at the house and I'm fortunate
enough to like live here right so I'm 20
minutes from Tommy so I yeah I would do
things like you know set it down be like
comment was this and he would be the
camera and then I'd be like well how
would you say it and he say it just like
you just like I thought and I mean it
was pretty easy man Tommy was always
kind of just stoked on even when you
read the dirt you can hear Tommy you can
you just cuz he's got such a distinctive
way of talking that you could almost
like hear him reading right right right
you got that down
I'm from for me Nikki I like I feel like
Nikki is such a different person now
than he was then you know he had such a
he's such a hard time with drugs and
with heroin and many other things and so
he really is a different person now so
when I went to me firstly I was
intimidated to go there and then he was
so warm he was so Zen and warm and
inviting and kind and so open and he
would do everything from like text me
guitar riffs to stuff like that but then
I remember Jeff Tremaine saying to me
remember he's a different person now and
you got to find what he was then so
that's what it was kind of the balance
of who he is now because they're alive
and it they've they've graduated as
people to different people you have to
kind of go back and find who they were
but lucky there's a lot of MTV
interviews and a whole lot of stuff you
cannot of manner of mannerisms you can
pick up from YouTube and stuff like that
so there's a whole blend of different
things I've spoken to a lot of actors
and when they're getting ready when
they're playing a real person when
they're they they latch on to a piece of
video or an interview or something and
they'll constantly go back to that like
right before they're about to go on set
to just remind them or put them in into
headspace did for the three of you did
you have something like that we had a
like that one common one that we loved
was the vh1 uncut yeah there was a and
also I remember with the dialect coach
she cut together like a whole string of
Nikki's interviews from different
periods and sometimes that you did the
same thing with Tommy and
yeah there's not that much yeah he
doesn't respect them but yeah and you
just listen to him repeating he just
kind of kick-starts you into that place
so trying to find something that they do
vocally or whatever that you can latch
on to yeah and the laughs is always a
good thing I find yeah yes I'm always
I'm always obsessed about deleted scenes
and what didn't make the final cut
do you remember anything that didn't
make the finished film I almost wish
Jeff would put together a blooper reel
because there was so many funny
burst out laughing scenes or Caesar so
you know and we spent a few days just
doing random stuff yeah montage bits but
bloopers are in out there somewhere
which you could get hold of was you know
there was a scene in the 24 hour
compilation where they put this camera
on me and they were essentially like
alright man like go go crazy break
everything in the hotel room and I was
breaking self nose breaking stuff and
then I got this lamp and it was kind of
like those moments where like no one was
yelling cut and it was just like silent
and I was like panicking and you know
I'm just looking around I grabbed this
lamp and I'm like I start cracking in
the shade ends up falling off and I'm
like whatever and I cracked it again and
you know it wasn't a prop lanthanum
actual light and it cracked my head open
I didn't make the cut man did you have
blood flowing you you what we're in that
scene where I get punched by Doc that
was about 30 seconds in the same scene
after I had just cracked the lamp but
but I think when I cracked the lamp I
blew the light that was the light for
the room all right so it didn't make it
because I you can stop and I whirling
the light it I'm also curious you guys
the costumes are great they look
obviously they're there right from the
era did you ever leave set with the
costumes and just take it for a spin
well I just try I try to steal my at the
end of the shoot I tried to steal my
girls girls girls pants they're like the
ones he wore on that till they like
leather and they have denim they're like
sick of like the red lacing and I had to
go to cool we go to do so can you send
the back the pants back because they
keep everything in a in a warehouse
until they know they don't need to do
reshoot so I'm still waiting for them to
be sent back because they're sick I won
those
Mick made me a replica of touch me I'll
kill you and send it to me which was
really cool
Teesha which he used to wear a lot and I
got into the film a couple of times but
I took that home obviously because mine
yeah you know my assortment of speedos
didn't make it I've got all those oh
yeah oh I already got it stop
I'm just gonna say congratulations for
real and I hope that you huge hit for
you guys okay so I mean nice to see
you